I don't think you realize just how
messed up the world is right now and
where we are headed governments are
rotting your savings through inflation
we have Wars breaking out across the
world the United States government has
just said that they want to fund both
Wars despite the fact that the US
government is in 33 trillion of debt
we're seeing an increase in
authoritarianism the health passports
are not going anywhere they still want
to implement that by 2030 so what's your
plan you need time and location Freedom
you need to be able to work from
anywhere in the world you need to be
completely independent not dependent on
any single entity for money or survival
if you are not working towards becoming
fully independent and Sovereign then you
are going to get left behind